CONDUCT OVERSIGHT TO PROTECT OUR
COUNTRY TO MAKE SURE IT NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN AND IT SHOULD
NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN, WHY NOT ALSO
INVESTIGATE AS WE MENTIONED THE
574 RIOTS IN THE SUMMER OF 2020
THAT WREAK HAVOC ON CITY AFTER
CITY WHILE DEMOCRATS EITHER
IGNORED IT BECAUSE IT WAS THEIR
BASE TO DOING IT, OR THEY JUST
SAID IT WAS MOSTLY PEACEFUL AND
LIED TO US, OR THEY ENCOURAGED
IT LIKE DEMOCRATS DID.
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY.
THERE HAS BEEN QUESTIONS ASKED,
ONCE THEY PULLED JIM JORDAN WHY
DIDN'T YOU REPLACE THEM WITH
OTHER PEOPLE?
IN RETROSPECT SHOULD YOU HAVE?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL BECAUSE
NOTHING WOULD BE DIFFERENT.
THINK OF THIS, IT IS ONLY THE
MAJORITY THAT HAS SUBPOENA
POWER.
THEY WOULD NEVER ALLOW
REPUBLICANS INTO THOSE MEETINGS
WHEN THEY INTERVIEW THE
INDIVIDUALS.
ALL THEY WOULD BE, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WOULD SIT UP THERE AND
THINK THIS IS A FAIR PROCESS.
REMEMBER ALSO WHATEVER
REPUBLICAN YOU PUT UP THERE,
NANCY PELOSI HAS TWO OKAY.
REMEMBER THIS COMMITTEE WHY IT
IS A LEGITIMATE, SHE STARTED IT
WITH BENNY THOMPSON WHO SAID
THERE'S ONLY ONE OPTION, WE
CAN'T KNOW WHAT NANCY PELOSI
SAID TO THE SERGEANT OF ARMS,
WHAT SHE SAID TO THE CAPITOL
POLICE OFFICER.
SHOULD THE VERY FIRST QUESTION
BE WHY WAS THE CAPITAL
ILL-PREPARED THAT DAY?
WHY WOULDN'T YOU LOOK BACK TO
WHEN THEY HAD NATIONAL GUARD'S
WHEN THE RIOTS WERE GOING ON IN
DECEMBER AT THE
LINCOLN MEMORIAL, NANCY PELOSI
COMPLAINING.
WHY WOULDN'T WE KNOW THAT?
AND REMEMBER WHAT THIS COMMITTEE
IS ALL ABOUT, THEY ALREADY
WANTED TO PREDETERMINE IT.
YOU ARE ABOUT TO GO FORWARD,
PEOPLE WILL THINK THIS IS A FAIR
PROCESS, HAVING THE MINORITY
HAVE A SAY.
NO, WE DO NOT.
WE DO NOT HAVE A SAY IN IT.
ONE OF THE BIG ARGUMENTS I HAD
WITH THE SPEAKER, IF WE WERE
GOING TO DO A --
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, I THOUGHT
IT WAS A GOOD IDEA.
I THOUGHT WE SHOULD HAVE ONE FOR
THE RIOTS OF 2020 AND FOR THIS
DAY BUT NOT ONE THAT WAS, THAT
HAD A PREDETERMINED OUTCOME AND
WOULDN'T ANSWER FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTIONS.
IF THEIR NARRATIVE AS
DONALD TRUMP WANTED THIS,
SUPPORTED THIS, BUT HE ORDERED
TROOPS TO PREVENT IT FROM
HAPPENING, THAT WOULD MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE IF THEY PRESENTED
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> REMEMBER WHAT REPUBLICANS DID
ON JANUARY 13TH, WE PREPARED ON
THE FLOOR THAT BOTH -- BOTH
SIDES HAVE SUBPOENA POWER THAT
WE LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED IN
AMERICA THAT ENTIRE SUMMER AND
ALSO LOOK AT WHY OFFICER ON
A GOOD FRIDAY GOT KILLED BY AN
INDIVIDUAL.
WE WOULD LOOK AT ALL THE
PROBLEMS AND WE WOULD NOT LET
NANCY PELOSI OFF.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHY THEY WERE
ILL-PREPARED TO MAKE SURE NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN.
>> Sean: OBVIOUSLY THE FIX WAS
IN FROM DAY ONE.
SAD.
BECAUSE THEY SHOULD MAKE SURE
THIS NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN, IN